[Musique]
je suis au honduras un petit pays
d'amérique centrale un des plus pauvres
du continent à san pedro sula la
capitale industrielle des milliers
d'ouvriers de makilas sont en train de
partir au travail
les deux tiers sont des femmes elles
fabriquent des vêtements pour des
marques internationales
adidas nike gap reebok
[Musique]
quand on parle de mondialisation
on pense d'abord au made in china en
réalité la mondialisation et partout
même dans un pays peu connu comme le
honduras je suis venu rencontrer des
ouvrières des femmes qui vivent grâce au
textile elle confectionne des tee-shirts
et des pantalons toute la journée
surtout pour le marché américain qu'est
ce qu'apporte la modélisation à ces
femmes un travail un meilleur niveau de
vie une indépendance à san pedro sula
soledad me guide
elle est ouvrière textile depuis 20 ans
elle a vécu l'expansion des usines les
crises
elle connaît les makilas de l'intérieur
il est 7 heures du matin je commence ma
journée de travail
[Musique]
je reste devant la porte de lusine
impossible d'obtenir une autorisation
d'entrée
[Musique]
je suis venu ici quand j'avais 20 ans
c'était le 11 juin 1990 j'ai commencé à
travailler le 12 juin dans une usine qui
s'appelait marcel internationale j'avais
envie de m'en sortir et j'ai choisi de
venir dans la province de cortes où sont
installés les makilas c'est là où il y
avait à l'époque les meilleures offres
de salaire
soledad habite à l'hommage del carmen à
bidonvilles à une heure de son usine le
quartier dangereux à cause des gangs les
maras chaque soir soledad à s'arrête
chez l'épicier barricadés pour se
protéger des voleurs tous les vendredis
le jour de sa paye elle y règle son
ardoise soledad a réussi à s'acheter une
petite maison il ya sept ans deux pièces
sans eau courante ni toilettes elle
partage sa chambre avec ses deux fils
andré et luis alberto soledad s'est
installé ici
après avoir était femme de ménage à
tegucigalpa la capitale
elle a repris les cours du soir il ya
quelques années elle avait envie d'une
vie meilleure
elle a obtenu un bac d'administration
j'ai eu mon diplôme à 28 ans mais j'ai
pas eu d'autre choix que de continuer à
travailler comme ouvrière j'ai cherché
un emploi pendant neuf mois sont trouvés
j'ai dû retourner à la makila
[Musique]
quelle est bonne j'ai enfin dans ce pays
à l'économie si fragile
le travail à l'usiné et l'emploi le plus
stable que ces femmes puissent trouver
mais il est peu payés 5 euros par jour
et les oblige à une organisation
quotidienne acrobatique nourrit une
camarade de soledad vie dans une chambre
de 15 mètres carrés sans fenêtres avec
son fils cadet
pablo est une amie ouvrière
[Musique]
ses quatre autres enfants sont chez sa
mère dans une autre ville
tout est g t au nom des mêmes
américano-canadien bienvenus j'ai dû
laisser les enfants chez ma mère parce
que je ne connaissais personne n'avait
la nueva j'ai commencé à vivre à
villanueva avec des amis jusqu'au jour
où j'ai pu louer tout seul on gagne très
peu il faut trouver comment survivre si
l'on donne à là on donne aussi à l'autre
imaginez qu'on prêche et six enfants
semaine je dois payer l'achat une autre
semaine
il faut que j'aie pelo une autre il faut
que j'achète des choses pour mon fils
une autre pour les enfants chez ma mère
à l'autre côté l'un des mes mains mais
c'est très compliqué à payer tout ça
[Musique]
moi je travaille dans une maculaire
parce que c'est le travail le plus
facile que l'on trouve ici au honduras
n'y a presque pas de travail pour les
femmes et c'est là où l'on va à peu près
gagner de l'argent pour pouvoir
améliorer un peu son quotidien
pour nelly soledad nourrit ce n'est pas
simple de joindre les deux bouts
pendant qu'elles sont au travail des
centaines de chômeurs s'entassent devant
l'entrée des usines
avec l'espoir de franchir les barrières
et de trouver un poste même s'il s'agit
d'un boulot de quelques jours les
premiers arrivés sont les premiers
servis
c'est la jungle de l'offre et de la
demande
beaucoup des ouvrières sont victimes
d'abus comme soledad en 2001
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé chez mac race de honduras
où il y avait beaucoup d'abus contre les
ouvrières nous sommes allés au centre
des droits des femmes pour dénoncer ces
pratiques
lorsqu'on a su que c'était moi la
responsable du groupe
on m'a viré et mon nom a été mis dans
une liste noire pour l'empêcher de
trouver du travail
du coup les femmes se serre les coudes
elles ont formé un petit groupe syndical
le toit de la maison viii nourrit leur
sert de lieu de réunion
soledad est la plus instruite la lecture
et l'écriture représente une vraie
difficulté pour ces femmes qui ont
arrêté l'école au niveau élémentaire
ce soir là elle prépare une présentation
de leurs activités militantes
[Musique]
grâce à leur détermination
elles ont obtenu une convention
collective et des améliorations pour
leur quotidien un uniforme de travail
une cuisine pour leur pause déjeuner
malgré la précarité de leur vie elles
avancent tout à coup la réunion se
transforme en fait c'est l'anniversaire
de nouri d'iris elles se sont toutes
cotiser pour leur acheter un gâteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2008 la crise mondiale a encore
aggravé les conditions de travail de
cette main d'oeuvre low cost
dans la région de san pedro de sula un
quart des travailleurs a perdu son
emploi parfois du jour au lendemain
comme c'est arrivé à gries depuis l'âge
de 14 ans et je viens d'avoir 28 ans
avant je travaillais dans une entreprise
qui s'appelait semapa real a fait
faillite
elle est partie du pays on nous a rien
donné
au honduras les usines ferment leurs
portes et réduisent le personnel sans
contrainte
ici tout le monde vit au rythme des
commandes au rythme de l'économie
mondiale il ya des cas où les patrons
tout simplement quitter le pays sans
avertir en laissant les machines
derrière eux il a fallu vendre tous les
équipements de lusine devenue fantôme
pour indemniser les travailleurs dans
cette période de récession les syndicats
sont la seule protection des
travailleurs ils ont longtemps été
interdit dans ces zones franches du
honduras ils sont aujourd'hui les goûts
certains dimanches les militants se
retrouvent pour partager leurs
expériences
[Musique]
nous sommes ici parce que nous voulons
faire respecter nos droits
mais si nous prenons peur camarades
alors il sera difficile pour nous de
réussir
[Musique]
les droits des ouvriers se limite à des
avances élémentaire partout dans les
usines règne un climat de méfiance de la
part des patrons les journalistes les
ong et les inspecteurs du travail ne
sont pas les bienvenus je multiplie les
demandes pour visiter des usines refus
par tous
le site green valley est le seul endroit
qu'on veut bien montrer aux étrangers
c'est une zone franche bâti par un
investisseur pakistanais qui comprend
plusieurs usines les seuls certifié iso
14001 dans le pays
deux cités grand propre verdoyant c'est
une vitrine dans la région de san pedro
[Musique]
les photos des usines sont interdites
je vole quelques images d'une usine de
fabrication de tissus du groupe
américain delta
[Musique]
les sites fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 et
les horaires de travail reste très
extensible dans une usine électronique
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de faire une
photo d'une jolie fille je ne suis pas
autorisé à faire plus ma visite est
terminée
[Musique]
vendredi c'est le jour de la paix devant
les usines et les vendeurs de vêtements
de chaussures et de dvd pirates
attendent les ouvriers les produits
viennent de la zone franche du panama
caillé à la main ils font leurs calculs
l'argent qui circule grâce aux salaires
des makilas représente 25% du pib du
pays
c'est la seule contribution que les
usines laisse au honduras le
gouvernement actuel n'a pas augmenté nos
salaires il a peur qu'un smic réévalué
puisse nuire à l'économie aux
industriels soledad préfèrent acheter
des vêtements d'occasion moins cher une
ironie pour cette femme qui passe sa vie
à coudre des vêtements de marque
la mondialisation a permis à soledad
être autonome d'élever ses deux fils
tout seul mais rien ne lui assure que
cela continuera na makila reste une
activité économique précaire
il y a toujours le danger de la
délocalisation vers un pays où les
salaires sont encore plus bas comme au
nicaragua au salvador voisin et americo
paul toute position prometteuse amis
[Musique]